[Music]
[Music]
fire
stop
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
we're out come on baby
yeah it was a hell of a soccer player
could have been Pro 1-0 almost over ow
one zero oh [ __ ] Harlan you got to be
careful with that mic
ah talk to HR yeah HR you're looking at
him
and he's wearing camels yeah we run hard
around him we run hard Harlan
um The Legend well one of the best
Comics ever I would say Harlan Williams
is one of the great Comics period and
I'm not kidding about that so you're
welcome for that compliment thank you
someone would say a tough follow oh yeah
it just gets up into this crowd well
he'll do your material better than you
he'll he'll do a hodgepodge of your
material he's done that to me many times
when I when I had
um I was doing the butter police and
then swine flu was out and you kept
talking about how the bacon police was
out there too oh yeah you did the bacon
police yeah why is the mic keep going
towards him I don't know but I don't
know try it again try it again it'll be
fine I don't have a chance and this is
insulting no you'll be fine
oh yeah a podcast I watched another day
no I know we were talking about the Road
Holland you don't like doing the road
this is the first podcast that hurts
physically
dude we're mainly around here oh we are
just all men dude we're men the Mike's
rough Chin's rough rough hands yep
you're not losing a stitch of your hair
buddy no these are plugs
yeah where'd you get the plugs Sweden
Sweden all uh all School uh choir boy
kids oh choir boy kids picked I picked
them online you can go on and look at
the different boys and pick what Harry
wants do you stress them out so that
they get a gray hair and then you take
it from them
I I I straighten them I have a hair
straightener and then I use this is a
secret but I use a little bit of food
food coloring it looks phenomenal yeah
could you um whatever you're doing
recommend to Brian because my friend
Brian over here decided to cut his hair
like a baby ostrich I I did a few so my
my wife heard the razor going and she
knows that when I'm when I have
something to do and my hair is looking
good and normal
I will say you know I have to make a
change
and I go downstairs and before anybody
can stop me I've shaved my head and she
comes down and goes no because she hates
it everyone hates it it's not like it's
probably not a flattering like a baby
chicken and then you got like the
the Russian
you know what's the Russian who's the
the the the the
Gorbachev you have the Gorbachev oh yeah
you know you have that right oh you mean
I have a bit of a birthmark there yeah
yeah yeah it's a I have the Russian the
Gorbachev birthmark on my head it's not
that noticeable dude oh the first thing
I saw well you're looking down Harley's
not short so he's not real Salt I
noticed it now that you said it what
shape is that it looks like it's uh
shaped my heart it looks like the shape
of the Arby's logo the cowboy hat that's
right oh it's brand but it's branding
it's an endorsement what it is I see
what you're doing there Dad
yeah we got the meat we got the meats
how funny Damien had a 666 and you've
got an Arby's cowboy hat yeah I can't
decide who's eviler well
um I am if you look at my body you can
tell I don't eat a whole lot of Arby's
and if I do it's without the bun right
I'd like the look of your body but I
just checked my schedule and it turns
out I'm busy for the rest of my life
it's just busy that's good there it is
very similar to the old school RV yeah
that's what you're that's where your
birthmark looks like you should open
your mouth and to turn into a
drive-through
yeah just let us put meat in there
am I right right hot meat show us your
meat hey mean up in the drive-through
you got the meat guys this is stupid oh
you got the beefs yeah yeah and the code
word is the code word is oh there's
Brian oh my God the code word is Arby's
look at that shape of Siberian you and
you and him should get together stick
your foreheads together and you'll
probably turn into Gal Gadot
not just the two of you pressing your
meaty red junk together
probably it's like Shazam you'd turn
into Gal Gadot so we so suddenly became
become one of the most beautiful women
in the world I I think so a way to find
out yeah I know her a little bit by the
way how through your birthmark well
through Instagram nope this is my dear
friend Patty Jenkins directed her in
Wonder Woman one Wonder Woman two never
heard of it they're not doing Wonder
Woman three apparently dear friend
dropper I know yeah I'm a friend dropper
but uh because Wonder Woman too
it's tough I don't know I don't how did
it how did Wonder Woman do too they
don't know because of covet right it was
uh it was it wasn't released it was
really I thought before that right oh
well 2020 yeah that's about coven it was
just tough all around I don't know 169.
a lot of money a lot of money they've
done yeah but it probably cost like 300
million to make correct so if it only
made one Mr box box office 412 million
that's no joke no it's called Temple
movie kids well that's that's Wonder
Woman one B okay I mean chin we're
talking about Wonder Woman No we're just
comparing the two yeah
uh there it is loses a hundred million
yeah yeah Wonder Woman lose 100 million
box office yeah yeah one one crushed
yeah the two was you know those movies
are always you know superhero movies
yeah you know you can't call it Wonder
Woman anymore right because of the
pronoun thing one Wonder person no just
wonder just wonder what are they yeah
yep just wonder they
well just wonder is what he said and
then you try under a brackets
Wonder just wondering then who knows by
the way I just bought my first on that
topic I just bought my first Wonder Bra
um my my man tits are coming in really
oh and I had to buy my first bra finally
yeah but you've been so athletic your
whole life you play Ice Hockey it
doesn't matter you can be athletic when
you hit uh 48 like I just did you're
gonna grow titties
it might be a little older than 40. well
I don't think I need you need my
assaults I thought I was I came out here
and was uh manly enough to talk about my
bosoms and biologically and you you body
shamed them right I did buy it
those tits are going to do well at uh
where'd you went to burning man right
that's how I saw you were just getting
ready to go to burn a man yeah I don't
know you don't strike me as Burning Man
guy we're doing sets I Laugh Factory and
yeah I was like we were talking about
you know this is months ago he's like
getting ready for burning man that's
surprising he's like you never ban him
like absolutely now he goes oh you gotta
go you had a good time I'd like to go
with you guys you guys would love it
wait you went to Burning Man what uh I
was there in the summer yeah are you a
big psychedelics guy no I just burning
man's more than everyone thinks it's
just a drug experience but it's it's a
it's a huge art experience it's a
spiritual experience it's a nature
experience do you go and stay in a uh
van I rent a uh an RV he does it proper
yeah he's not sleeping on the ground you
ride an RV I have an RV with a shower
and uh and a kitchen an AC and heating
but but then when you're not in the RV
you're out just enjoying the madness and
it's in in correct me if I'm wrong
because our boy Schultz went he was
saying like there's no currency as far
as like money like money doesn't get you
things like people like I'll massage
your foot for a loaf of bread or
whatever is that how it goes yeah I got
seven uh loafs of Wonder Bread for
giving someone a full uh Happy Ending
yeah they were just asking for a foot
rub I didn't know that well you're there
no I know
let's go that extra yard or inch but
you've been to burn a man how many times
this is my fifth time really yeah but
it's not it's yeah there's no money
there you can't buy anything once you're
in the festival you can't there's
nowhere to buy anything so if if you
everyone kind of works on the principle
of just giving so if you need a sandwich
or a drink you can just knock on
someone's like RV and say hey man
do they have to do it I don't have to
but everyone's in that Spirit that's
what's beautiful and nobody greets with
a handshake it's always a hug everyone
hugs but this sounds like a very druggy
experience and you're dead sober and
you're still good without sandwiches
it's a communal experience it's communal
but there are people that you know do do
drugs and have fun with drugs and
there's you know I went up there once
with two sober people I drove two sober
girls up there it's gonna be as fun
though yeah it is fun because it it's
sort of like if you ever watch those
early Star Treks with William Shatner
and they get in the trans Porter and all
of a sudden they're on another planet
yeah this is what burning man is like
I'm not kidding I've been all over the
world right I've Been Everywhere yeah
I've never when you get to Burning Man
and it's night time and all the lights
and lasers it's like you just
transported to another planet there's
nothing like it it's like Mad Max that
sounds like I had an amazing I had a
friend of mine who invited me and uh and
he said it's
10 grand and I went what no no and he
goes no and he goes but what we do is we
rent these giant um high high priced
buses and we bring a sushi chef and we
bring an Italian chef
that's what I'm saying and then they
Circle the buses so nobody can come into
your circle I was like let's not do that
right that's something you drive all the
way up that's not a burning man that's
not the experience no it is it's
whatever you want it to be so there's
people that do it really high end like
that and spend a fortune sounds like
your friend's part of the skull right
and then there's people who who
literally will sleep in their car or in
a tent on the ground and but a ticket to
burning man's about 400 500 and that's
first for almost 10 days there's musical
acts nope there's no musical acts it's
all DJs and it can be an 80s party it
can be a disco party it can be there
there's there's a million different
things going on and then do you dress up
like The Mad Max you can dress up you
can be naked it you can just dress how
you normally dress it's what it's
whatever you want how much time you
spend there how many days uh normally I
go for five but this year I went last
year I went for the whole thing because
for two years they shut it down for
covet oh so when I went last summer I
was like damn it I'm doing the whole
like the whole thing are you there when
that guy jumped into the fire I was
right in front of him you were so I
watched him jump in the fire and die
yeah no it was horrifying you serious
I'm serious I was he so 70 000 people
the second last night they burned the
man the burning man is like this 70 foot
tall wooden man and on the second last
night everyone surrounds him but they
have to be back like I'd say about
almost 80 90 feet 100 feet because the
fire it rages is like a hundred feet
high and 60 feet wide it's a huge fire
sacrifice Jesus and I'm sitting in the
throngs of seventy thousand people and
some guy got up out of the crowd and
started running around towards the fire
the guards are trying to grab them it's
like when you see a guy jumping on a
football field or baseball and he was
evading them and then all sudden he just
turned he literally put his hands
together and dove into the fire and it
was just happened to be right in front
of me holy [ __ ] it was pretty pretty
traumatized he he just died right there
he or did he come out like uh games
no they said he didn't die there but I
was right in front of him and what
happened is one of the Brave guys so the
security guys that are standing between
the crowd and the fire these guys are
dressed in these fire suits to you know
repel the heat yeah and this guy risked
his own life and he reached in and
grabbed the guy really fast and dragged
him out on the ground and his body was
just smoldering yeah he wasn't on fire
but it would you could see smoke coming
and I'm thinking that we were 90 feet
back and I almost had to get up and move
because of the heat yeah so imagine
jumping into the heart of the fire and
inhaling you would incinerate with your
life the smoke is what gets you yeah
yeah you don't burn alive it's the smoke
right yeah the smoke and the extreme
heat probably I'm sure he'll be right
there but like in house fires they say
it's the smoke it's the smoke go down
first yeah that that intense heat though
for even a couple seconds like you said
you breed that [ __ ] in you're done they
said he lived but I I I don't think he'd
I saw him laying there he might have but
he got in they put him in the ambulance
and then they said the next morning he
died but I don't know how he said first
of all he was clearly on everything
that's all I was gonna say he had to be
on Molly or the health kid it's hard
because I've read articles about it and
they said he wasn't but I don't know if
that's PR but he was jumping around
euphorically like he was he looked
elated he looked happy seeing him right
now he was prancing that's him he looks
like he's saying an avatar he was an
athletic guy and he looked happy and
everyone was at first everyone was
cheering because they thought he was
just playing tag with the security guys
yeah and then all of a sudden he just
turned and dove in he decided to die you
know and what's sad he apparently he was
there with I think
um 12 or 15 friends so they had to watch
it and then apparently I think he had a
wife and kids
and it was just really
um wait that is that oh my God so he and
he didn't even make it like to the dude
I mean look at that that's an inferno
that must have been hard for you that
guy or one of those guys went and
ran in and grabbed him by the foot that
guy's a badass yeah that's that [ __ ] is
um
that's traumatizing that'll ruin your
[ __ ] Burning Man experience sorry to
bring that up no you know what I did at
the when it happened I was sitting with
about 15 friends
and everyone was just kind of shocked
and mortified and
and I sort of immediately I don't know
why or how but and I don't know if it
was the appropriate thing to do but I
immediately took a leadership role
and after about five minutes I gathered
all of them up in a circle and I said
guys let's join hands and pray yeah
because we've just seen someone pass or
we assumed they had passed and and this
is going to affect us and I I think
whether you believe in God or in in any
type of entity whatever you believe in I
think it's this is important that we
Channel and pray right now
because I think going forward you might
look back and go I'm glad we did and I
don't know if it helped anyone but it
sure helped me because well you know
like there's energy right something
happens to you I don't give a [ __ ] who
you are something like that happens to
you something's going on here in your
body right yeah if you have nothing to
fall back on yeah right like so so if
you're left to contend with that that
can lead to [ __ ] that can lead you down
paths you're not aware of like you don't
know what I'll do it might make you
cynical it might make you hysterical it
might make you angry but but there's I I
really believe as I get older that look
into the sky and and uh
having somewhere to put that
energy yeah yeah and that's really what
you're doing is giving it up to
something you don't understand that's
bigger than yourself
navigate through it therapy will
probably lead you the same place right
so sometimes therapy will like the idea
would be okay this happens in the world
I can tell you not to worry about it I
can give you tools to cope with it but
ultimately you're gonna have to have
some kind of faith that there's a reason
for that if you don't and you go in a
cynicism and you say well that's life
and it's we're just monkeys on a rock
and we're all going to die and there's
no point to anything good luck with that
that doesn't lead you anymore good luck
with that nihilistic approach I've seen
it I agree and that's why I sort of
pulled the other group members into it
because you know in Hollywood a lot of
the times people will make fun of you
for being a person of Faith or believing
in God or believing in anything okay so
I just I myself I didn't know what their
belief system was or how they felt about
higher power but I just said let's get
everyone together really fast and and
channel this and and and and and and
sort of Channel this guy's Spirit
through us and also at the same time
kind of release what we're feeling it
was it was very emotional did that
surprise you that you did that
it's it did and it didn't because I I'm
used to being in a leadership role but I
I also it it surprised me that I just
instinctually did it yeah and I think I
did it for me I knew I needed it but I
also saw these other friends of mine
just all everyone was in the days and I
thought I think yeah something's telling
me I need this they needed to and if we
do it together it might be you know
triple is powerful and we all we all
held and there were tears and it was wow
you're a bit of a shaman yeah
let's take a break let's take a little
break from the shenanigans with our boy
Harlan one of the greats one of the
greats maybe you know him from Dumb and
Dumber Something About Mary everything
Half Baked he's still doing it stand up
killer let me ask you a question what
dude do I look tired you look tired you
know why dude why are you not sleeping
on a helix mattress they took my Helix
from me bro that's what happens stop
sleeping on Hay stop sleeping on marble
I've been trying to be like liver King
no don't do the bamboo thing let me
explain something I need Helix dude
Helix has 14 unique mattresses including
a collection of luxury models a mattress
for Big and Tall like you and even a
mattress made just for kids my kids
start there yes dude yes you can take a
helix sleep quiz and find your perfect
mattress in under two minutes and your
personalized mattress is shipped
straight to your door free of charge
Helix knows there's no better way to
test out a new mattress than by sleeping
on it in your own freaking crib that's
why they offer a 100 night this free
trial 100 nights try out your new Helix
mattress see how your body adjusts and
if you decide it's not the best fit but
you will you're welcome to return it for
a full refund they've got they got
memory foam it creates optimal pressure
relief if you sleep on your side they
have more responsive foam to cradle your
body for essential support and stomach
this is the most important they'll be
enhanced cooling features to keep you
from overheating at night I I'm a sweaty
sleeper you're a sweaty sleeper daddy
runs hot you hot sleeper I hot sleep you
hot sleep a hot sleep if you hot sleeper
cool sleeper Helix got you we got you
100 nights you tried risk-free you don't
love it but you gotta get it for you yep
you gotta do what I did and that's why I
sleep like a baby unless I'm sleeping on
bamboo like the liver King all you do is
take the Helix sleep quiz and I was
matched with a perfect big and tall
model mattress just for me all right and
I like it hard I like it firm I sleep on
my side on your time I'm on my side not
my tummy
yeah I'm not a baby that's crazy all
right so Helix is offering you guys up
to 200 dollars off all mattress orders
and two free pillows for the finally kid
listeners and viewers go to
helixsleep.com fighter that's h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com slash fighter with Helix
better sleep starts now they also
support military First Responders
teachers and students by giving them a
special discount on site how about that
it's America because it's cold season
it's like you got to take care of him
you gotta get your you got to get your
minerals you got to get your vitamins
you got to get your probiotic you got to
get your prebiotics I just swallow like
30 vitamins and like you could do that
you could do that enjoy that but you
want to get your greens you want to get
your fruits you can do one scoop of
agree love it contains 75 minerals
vitamins a whole food sourced ingredient
all of it it's a multivitamin
multi-mineral probiotic green superfood
blend that will blow your mind it's
tasty bioavailable ingredients in a
scoop of ag1 work together
traditional gaps in your diet support
energy Focus Aid with gut health
digestion supports a healthy immune
system dude your immune system needs to
be rocked hard right now and you'll be
rocked up with ag-1 some of the most uh
successful people I know take it every
single day oh I swear by man
podcasters moms dads aunts rookies first
timers Comics everybody everybody used
it so to make it easy athletic greens is
giving you a immune supporting free one
year of supply of vitamin D and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase if you visit athleticgreens.com
fighter again all you got to do is go to
athleticgreens.com fighter to take
control of your health and give ag-1 a
try yeah yeah who's going to heaven
first me or Brendan and it's okay Heaven
he just recently got did you say heaven
wow Heaven yeah
okay well you do have the mark of the
beef on your head
it's not helping yeah that's not well
you'll be down there with Damian uh
eating all the Horsey Sauce but it's the
beef not curly fries
like curly fries on your eyes and
pretend you're Dolly Parton and hell no
and grow some tits yeah I'll blend you
my Wonder Bra guy
I mean I heard Tammy Faye Baker and Jim
Baker used to swing and he used to like
to watch her get who's this dick down
people don't know who that is Tammy Faye
Baker and Tim Baker the Evangelical yeah
they got they got put in jail for tax
evasion or he did you don't remember Tim
Baker and Tim bring it up oh they did a
whole TV show evangelist oh yeah you
remember these guys don't you they look
like they died uh-huh but it's not easy
to see someone die I've seen two people
die in my life and the second one was a
nine-year-old boy that would make it
worse because I I would assume before
you tell that's right I'd assume what
made this a little bit easier to cope
with is it was his decision at least you
didn't see it was pushed you see him get
shot yeah at least he was like that's
how I want to do it so part of that's
like all right well that's his choice I
can deal with that nine-year-old boy who
that that's where he gets done that
one's hard because that one was sort of
my fault too the nine-year-old what do
you mean yeah uh you want to hear this
one no yeah not if it's too much well
it's it's uh you want to hit it it's
like it's something I have to deal with
in my life but I was up in San Francisco
about two years ago
visiting a friend and I'm driving home
in the night and you know between San
Francisco and L.A it's pretty empty
right
and I'm going through them every now and
then you see the odd random you know
restaurant or truck stop or whatever
this place house pie shop and I'm I'm
just passing it
and something runs across the road in
the dark okay it's not a human it's an
animal
and I'm like and you know you feel the
thumping and you you what the hell did
it and you kind of look in the rearview
mirror but it's dark so you can't tell
so I just keep going I keep going and
I'm like okay it was an animal I felt
horrible I get all the way home
I hear like a noise when I stop the car
I look up jammed under my grill a bobcat
have you ever seen a bobcat yeah a
freaking like a predatory cat I have a
bob animals the big pause and it's like
yeah like it it's and I'm like holy [ __ ]
I go and get to one of those uh like
those and live animal cages and I I'm
like holy [ __ ] I pull this thing out of
here it's semi-unconscious
and I'm like for [ __ ] sakes and I look
and I got the thing on the ground and
it's a it's a female it's it's lactating
it's teats are dripping yeah no no I
hate to see the Lord is the scientific
word though
right it's a weird thing the teeth are
dribbling they're dripping yeah this
thing's been through some [ __ ] there's
things I I drove about 300 miles
in a grill while you're lactating so now
I'm emotionally connected to this thing
because now I know if the teeth are
dripping yeah there's some toddlers back
up by House pies [ __ ]
and so I got this thing stuffed in the
live animal cage the next morning I
drive all the way back I said those
those babies need the mama good on you
man right it was I had to drive 300
miles back with this thing in the cave
and now you've always been a cat guy I
love animals I love cats that's all the
kids need the mom yeah that's right the
kids need the milk they need the teeth
milk yeah and she's probably swollen at
this point there's you know yeah they're
full and so this thing's not happy being
in the cage no so the further north I
get the more enraged this thing gets
right okay oh you brought you brought
mama cat with you well I had to bring it
back I'm going back to house house I
thought you're gonna go get the kitties
bring them back to your house
back in their wild environment so sorry
so now the only Landmark I have for
point of reference is house House of
Pies so I get up there I pull into the
park and I go over to The Far Side open
the the car put the live animal cage up
I open the door and this cat is it's I'm
scared that it's going to attack me it's
bobcat
I open the thing this thing runs out as
fate would have it
of families just coming out of house
House of Pies yeah and I later learned
the kid's name uh Scotty McCracken
Scotty McCracken that's a tough nice
Scottish kid when we get emotional we
tend to correctly yeah
and this kid came out of the House of
Pies nine years old and nine Scotty you
knew he was Scottish had the red air the
freckles his teeth he looked like a
grouper
and I'm not sure
local key lime pie I didn't know that
grouper's had teeth it doesn't matter
fangled up Scottish yeah
and this kid's walking out with his
family here's this raging Bobcat
sees this kids I don't know if red you
know how Bulls charge it red yeah yeah
cats have that thing too Bobcats
Wildcats do key lime pie triggers it
right and and so off he goes makes a bee
line at the Scotty mccrack it's a little
red the red yeah on his throat down what
rips his [ __ ] throat everywhere lemon
meringues key lime pie all over the
place oh no and then this cat I guess it
got out and just bolted into the woods
and and took a beeline ran out and got
hit by a truck an 18-wheeler so mama cat
got hit by a [ __ ] truck after all
that work after all that now the babies
are perished or did you adopt the babies
no the babies heard their mother they
came running out and they got hit they
all do it they ate the key lime pie
beforehand so they weren't starving yeah
well so that was a tough one but so I
sort of feel like I Scotty McCracken who
is Scotty so Scotty McCracken was was
where if you could not make fun of his
voice I mean that's how you say it in
Scottish you said he was Scottish I know
but it's not like he eats at McDonald's
just because he's no I'm saying that you
said his name was Scotty McCarthy right
so he was with his family and and the
cat yeah Bobcat
let's put this through it and there was
I think I am pay everywhere everywhere
now did he perish or did you mend his
three he had like a seizure he was you
know the blood was leaving and he was
saying it spasming all over the parking
lot lad and uh this is a boy as Heritage
goes back to Edinburgh and don't forget
you can hear the cats going is that
being dragged down the highway screaming
and then you hear the babies popping on
the road with the 18 wheeler goes
popping yeah
Halloween they're like a bubble wrap
when you get seven or eight of them
together they just pop up terrible
almost kind of fun uh the same thing
what almost well I didn't mean the last
part did you say Farm no I said Family
fam fam fam yeah but it's so Scotty
McCracken is bleeding right he's
bleeding you know I'll fix his three you
can't fix it the weak cat slipped it so
wide it's like looking at Raquel Welch
spread eagle as a gynecologist
but then you must have in some way felt
that uh it was a good thing that is
[ __ ] God that took Scotty McCracken's
three right that there's this divine
retribution because the [ __ ] car and
his stupid Lair got popped on the
[ __ ] hay way right so in a way in a
way the parents and the family must have
felt something indication and that they
were Avenged by their maker well what
learned their welfare McCracken families
I felt so bad about the wheelad I went
into hell's House of Pies yeah and I
purchased a chocolate cream pie and gave
it to the family I would have eaten it
myself because I my stomach is so queasy
when a sick cat's day like that that's
the difference between me and you lad if
I have my if I murder a boy I buy the
family a pie if you murder a boy you eat
the pie yourself well that's the way I
am
but hey I didn't think I didn't think
sorry about that guys I didn't go into
burning man would go down such a door
yeah
no he's been through a lot but he's been
through a lot but you did make it right
with a pie and the the wasted time but
you know yeah the motto of the story is
if you if you get a bobcat caught in
your grill you kill that Bobcat I think
you meant to say the moral of the story
because a motto is kind of like a moral
like a motto would be kill kid get pie
that would be the motto tomorrow the
moral is the moral is if you if you got
a bobcat stuck in your [ __ ] Grill
then I don't care if it's lactating
you know let it milk out let it melt or
I think the the moral of the story is if
you see a bobcat on the highway you
speed up
speed up there you go
you speed up what's the moral of the
story if you're scuba diving
and Amore eel comes out at you and bites
you I've had that experience but it
didn't bite me
so would that be the Moray of the story
pause
don't point at me bro I'll fly over this
Brendan [ __ ] take you down guys I'll
fly right over Brendan and [ __ ] slap
you you get a crazy I've already I've
already Rick lastman already slapped the
[ __ ] out of me in my last episode and
you have a crazy look in here like a
crazy yeah right it's a haircut since he
walked in it's infuriating yeah well
what do you think I know when was the
last time you gotten a dust up you're
getting this you're ever getting a dust
oh yeah I was vacuuming yesterday and
Mike my hold on that's a that's an
expression for a fight for a fist fight
on the street
okay okay if you're Are you seriously
asking yeah okay who messes with Harlan
Harlan I'd be surprised people go ah you
think you're all famous because you were
in that [ __ ] movie Etc that movie but
I but I bet when you go to like burning
man I'm sure people there's five that's
right Dumb and Dumber that's one of the
oh oh yeah yeah I bet all of them are
like little pumpkin pie here get well I
do get recognized at Burning Man but
it's hard to get recognized there
because everyone's got goggles and
they're covered in dust and it people
can really go Incognito like that in the
bowling shirt no man I wear jeans and an
old t-shirt
you got to buy a bunch of gear to go to
burning man because there's dust storms
every day there's twirling dust storms
that blow through the whole thing oh no
desire no but here's the thing everyone
says that but it's almost like part of
the uniqueness of it and it it it
unifies everyone because whether you're
a hot Victoria's Secret model or Elon
Musk or you know Leonardo DiCaprio
whoever's there the dust kind of UNIF
and I'm gonna dress up as a bobcat whoa
bro little ears how about you dress up
as a pie or maybe Scotty mccrack and oh
a little red McCracken I'll get uh
that'd be adorable freckles I did get in
a dust up recently though and yeah I
volunteer
um down at uh at uh the um Mount
Pleasant Senior Center every uh every
Saturday I go down every Saturday every
Saturday I go down and I could give back
and I go to the senior center and what I
do is I I sponge bath the oldies I like
to put you call them oldies or no not in
front of them but I know that I
appreciate I'm sorry I interrupted you
SpongeBob I wasn't call them the
wrinkles so you give the oldies a
SpongeBob give the oldies a sponge bath
and I like to put put seven or eight in
the tub of the top
we're listening well come on chin sorry
I mean he's helping out so you put a lot
of them in a time I put a lot so I can
get them all at the same time and I like
to drizzle onion water on them just it's
good for why onion water well it's good
have you ever had psoriasis I have I
never used onion water I'm sorry I keep
getting wise geez this is news I
apologize go on so uh Mrs Parkinson one
time I was I was drizzling onion water
on her
okay you know I'm not I'm literally
listening I know but you I see you she's
chuckling I'm not chuckling Chin's not
mature and you Jin needs to grow up and
then also you had psoriasis you could
have called him drizzle I just
appreciate you take your Saturdays and
you and you and you sponge bath the
oldies yeah and you group them yeah and
one time uh Mrs Parkinson I got uh I
drizzled I had this sponge uh from uh
Bed Bath and Beyond to get the big the
big ones the orange ones and I was yeah
I was drizzling onion water on her face
and it got in her eyes
and she stood up and you know you've I
don't know if you've ever been in a
fight with the lady from the The Shining
who's in the bathtub but this yeah this
one stood up and she cold cocked me bro
I don't know what she used to do when
she was younger yeah bam I'm on the
floor yeah I bounce back up like Gumby
that just uh you know sniffed a sea
urchin fart and I'm like Bam Bam Bell
right in her face get in the face she
kicked me just missed the jewels and
because she was a little off balance
uppercut bam right under her teeth fly
out oh she's sticking the [ __ ] wall
yeah down yeah and then you look at the
other old people go who else wants some
yeah I said anyone else want to party
yeah now are you naked when you sponge
no no I wear uh plastic suit like a
hazmat suit yep he don't catch anything
yeah well I didn't know you were into uh
into charity but you're obviously going
to heaven before any of us are yeah I
have a great charity I don't know if I'm
allowed to mention it on your show no
please I have uh I have a charity uh
called cinnamon Angels fly fly away and
it's uh for children with cinnamon
allergies and uh it's a great Foundation
we we uh put all the money towards uh
the foundation to help kids with
cinnamon allergies great sponsored by
Cinnabon
well
it's a good joke it's a good time well I
don't know if we should joke about
children without cinnamon allergies I
feel like you could give back more of
his like peanut allergies right well
there's a lot of Charities for that but
uh cinnamon Angels fly fly away just
specifically deals with children with
cinnamon allocation now I'm gonna I'm
gonna take the conversation I want to
get your perspective on
on we're all getting older yeah and the
world's changing quickly yeah right and
the business is changing at 100 miles an
hour and a million entertainment don't
you feel like oh don't you I don't know
this is how I feel I feel like an all
[ __ ] aside I feel like the business
is changing so quickly that if you said
what are you going to be doing in five
years I don't know hopefully stand up
and hopefully everything but five years
five months he literally I constantly
change it literally yeah and and trying
to stay relevant in this world with so
much noise yeah like I don't do you ever
get exhausted with that do you ever no I
look forward to it and what I do is I
record on my iPhone every single
stand-up show I do whether I'm doing
20-minute spot or a full hour like
concert at a theater or wherever I am I
record them all because I'm looking
forward to the day
when I don't even have to tour and
they're going to take all these
recordings and turn them into Holograms
or turn them into some type of
artificial intelligence where people can
press a button and I can appear in their
living room as some form of Technology
with Elvis doing with Michael Jackson
the only problem I guess when you're
older and you can't travel because your
health or whatever but then you're going
to miss out on the you know the Jews
well Willie Nelson will you know you're
saying way down the road yeah these are
these are recordings that I already have
so they'll be able to use I've got
hundreds of shows I've recorded so down
the road when this technology hits when
I camp you down the road anymore yeah
people can still watch an original show
I think Bruce Willis was the first to
sell his name in likeness once that
happens he was like the first major
celebrity so [ __ ] weird but I mean
that makes a lot of sense that's [ __ ]
weird it's weird but it's cool it's it
and it's like so your optimist stick I'm
optimistic that we live in perpetuity if
if we have the material so I would
recommend that every comedian record
every show they ever do and just keep it
now if you I do I do with my shows I
usually do something different every set
because I do a lot of crowd work
[ __ ] incredible you can win perform
at the Laugh Factory just a tough crowd
there's some good comics on there and
even you and I were sitting there you're
like man they're tough and then oh yeah
manager and I was like man this [ __ ]
crowd tonight she's like Harlan watch
Harlan I told you I told you to watch it
you did crowd work it was you just got
up there and was like where are you from
and it was often
I've told the story I told the story six
times but it's worth repeating maybe the
greatest thing I've ever seen done by a
comic on stage I'm not joking was we're
in Pittsburgh
and like it was me Steve Byrne it was it
was like all Headliners
this was at a big theater in Pittsburgh
for this radio station they put it on
that's right yeah Harlan was closing and
it was like one not but everybody was
good and everybody was [ __ ] did their
thing across that room and then Harlan
had to get up and to me this is I I
think about it like I've never seen
anything like this he you're watching
him and the audience is watching him and
he's doing
all of our all of our sets
he does them back to the audience but
he's adding his thing on it right and
and it took that people a while they
were like is he drunk he's using he's
doing the same jokes and then he would
start then he would add his thing into
it and the dude we're all like this
and then the audience it was it was like
because he had to follow everybody who
was crushing and and then he just
absolutely destroyed for about 45
minutes and that's when I was like oh
there are levels to this month Ryan
talks about that once a week once a week
man yeah but I just I couldn't believe
first of all you remembered everybody
set second of all you were able to take
it and twist it into your own but he did
that to me at the Laugh Factory one time
on the spot yeah at the Laugh Factory
one time he did a whole thing where I
did the butter police where I take
liberal and you know and I'll do it all
I think and he [ __ ] at he just
started doing that then you started
coughing and going me
like you you had you know you had swine
flu and you had to start you know I'm
sure it's nothing and dude I don't know
I I you had to be there well that comes
from I I like to challenge myself when I
get up on stage just about every time
yeah and so when I do theater shows with
groups of comics like I think the most I
did was ten once Jesus and so what I do
is I sit at the back or if I can't get
to the back I'll stand at the side and
I'll watch everybody's act and
everybody's Act is usually you know 12
to 20 minutes long when you do a thing
that long and you know the crowd's
getting tired and if I'm closing I go I
want to do something to so I'll watch
everyone's act and then I'll listen for
a piece and I go okay I like that piece
that they just did about chasing a dog
and then I'll listen to the next
person's piece and maybe they'd do a bit
about someone broke into their house and
then the next person does a bit about
their grandmother or whatever so I'll
find a piece and everyone's act and I'll
find a way to join them together so now
I'm chasing my dog and I had to break
into somebody's house and then I found
their grandmother so I'll take a piece
of everyone's act and form a story with
a piece of everyone's act until I have a
full bit and the hardest part is
remembering everyone's act well the
hardest part is making as funny as you
do yeah that's what's degree of
difficulty there's he's doing it on the
spot you start you start stand up in uh
Toronto Toronto yeah yeah it was just
how long ago oh I started in the early
80s I mean I I worked at a club I
remember seeing um Sam Kinison going up
in front of me Bobcat goldthwaith all
these who are your Heroes did you have
any Comics that were Your Heroes Comics
or Your Heroes authors
I love stand-up comedy obviously but I I
never those weren't really my influence
I think I was influenced more by comedic
actors like the the guys from Second
City John Candy John Candy Martin Short
Joe Flaherty Monsters uh Harold Ramis
Dave Thomas Harold Raymond Eugene Levy
Catherine O'Hara Catherine O'Hara yeah
so you would you're doing stand up in
Toronto and then you would come to LA
right you started getting your shops in
La too and then no I I
um I went I started in Toronto I did
about
five about six years
and then I knew I wanted to get to La
and I was just about to go and I ended
up going to Germany and living in
Germany for a year and a half and then
from Germany I ended up making my way to
La after about seven years of wait you
building Germany yeah what were we doing
in Germany I was doing computer
animation
so what yeah wait a minute because that
was his major right that was your major
and I studied animation yeah in college
yeah so what happened is my my my buddy
in college Bob Angelini
he went over after college to work in
Germany in an animation studio
and just by Fate that winter I phoned
him to say what are you doing for
Christmas and he goes oh I'm here in
Germany alone I said dude I don't want
you to be alone I'm coming over for two
weeks you know to hang out and spend the
holidays with them so I went over and
I'd just written a Siri written and
Illustrated a series of children's books
called lickety-split about a little
dinosaur
and he hadn't seen them yet so I took I
took like five of them over there was a
whole series to give to him and the day
after I got there he got fired from his
jobs and I was like Jesus so I say you
know I'm a bit of an entrepreneur so I
said Bob call your boss is up set up a
meeting I'm gonna go in with my
children's books and see if I can sell
them an animated series so that you know
we can do an animated show so I go in
the next day with my kids books I show
them I do the whole pitch they brought
out a bottle of champagne and said let's
do it we love it I said under one
condition you hire my buddy Bob back
so they said yes and next you know I'm
there a year and a half working on this
project my buddy Bob's there right back
in there's amazing for your buddy visit
you get you your job back and I'll get a
job right but then full circle like
obviously animations in your background
and then you have a show now my kids
watch it yeah here's the show right now
is it Nickelodeon uh Disney Disney puppy
dog Pals yeah oh my God I'm a big show
it's in its fifth season and it's like
their top show on uh Disney World Disney
Junior
obsessed with it oh my God so what's
funny is when I started that did that
computer animation back then this was at
the Advent of computer animation it was
just starting so in order to render one
computer drawing it could be in the
system for half a day just to make like
two steps it would take hours and hours
and hours
and now you know cut to you know now I'm
doing puppy dog Pals where we we do I
think we do 70 shows a season Jesus wow
and it's crazy that's all that's created
yeah I created it you created that whole
that you created that seriously yeah
it's all him and I do the voice one of
the voices that's why you came here in a
helicopter yeah yeah well it goes to
Burning Man is that that's your creation
Harlem yeah I created that show I went
in and pitched it to uh Disney and uh it
was a very funny process they you know
we went in to pitch them some
some animation ideas
and I pitched them about four or five
animation ideas and like great thanks
for coming in and I said hey thanks for
having me and and I was literally like
getting up out of my chairs about this
high up I was like just standing up and
the lady goes do you have any other
ideas and I go well in my head I'm going
to go out because I you know I knew I
had a problem that didn't work yeah yeah
and I went well I have this one called
Puppy Dog Pals and I sat down and
pitched it in about like four minutes I
just kind of told them to kind of like
okay thanks and cut to you know five
years later it's like the top show on
holidays yeah and Tom Kenny is is that
the comic Tom Kenny Tom does the voice
of SpongeBob but he does the voice he
was a comic yeah he was a stand-up
SpongeBob's voice and he does these are
some of the people that do show uh
voices on my show oh my gosh um
we've got Sherry oteria I got her in
there to do a voice she's great Huey
Lewis does a voice Tom Kenny yeah
do you know any other Huey Lewis all
right come on guys all right yeah I mean
I didn't know who's your nutty friend
I'm sorry all right dude who's
Springsteen the singer
look and you have Bruce Springsteen
Sharia Terry's great man we had a lot of
guests some uh Bill Byrd did a guest a
couple of guest voices yeah that's what
I like when I can hear it's people
obviously you know my son's watched it
so yeah okay here we go yeah but then
when you hear a different voice I'm like
oh that's cool yeah we've had a lot of
fun fun guest voice how is Huey Lewis
doing is he doing uh he's good we
actually got him to do one song he said
he wasn't gonna sing and and they were
able to talk him into doing one original
song on on the show so yeah is he still
touring stuff uh I think it to be honest
I think his hearing's going a little bit
so I don't know how much he does anymore
but I assume a lot of those people went
on there because their kids watch the
show yeah that's what Bill Bird did he
he loved the show with his kids and then
and then I reached out to him I said
come on in let's get you doing a voice
and he did he did a couple of episodes
and I think he scored a lot of points
with his kids for that yeah the biggest
is that one and then uh Paw Patrol yeah
Paw Patrol was out
how do you get paid for that do you rent
your show to Disney
uh no you you have to make a deal with
them where you you kind of have to go
through all the steps from from what
your role is as the Creator the producer
piece of the merchandise I'm just gonna
say more time massive I just got Boston
he had his birthday that's what he
wanted oh he bought him some toys thanks
yeah you're welcome hopefully that
thanks wow they give you a good cut on
that oh that's how I got the helicopter
that makes sense and you're able to take
the time on Saturdays to SpongeBob
sponge bath over at Mount Pleasant
Senior Center yeah what a good guy so
besides crushing on the puppy dog Pals I
see so you're doing stand up and then
Toronto and then you go to Germany you
do well there with the animation they
come to LA and then really the huge kind
of breakout was the Dumb and Dumber
right I feel like that's the most quoted
thing almost that was my first movie
yeah yeah of your first movie my first
movie yeah you did a bunch of stuff
after that after that yeah that sort of
opened the doors do you like making
movies or do you hate it I love it I
mean well the process can be very
tedious at times as you know but it it
uh it's like getting there for stand-up
it's like the travel yeah it's waiting
in the trailer and like I just we just
shot Half Baked two what and did Neil
Brennan read it no no it's a whole new
group I just did a cameo in it it's a
whole new group of kids
uh I don't think Jim did anything but uh
Rachel true and myself and and uh um
Jeff Ross and David keckner oh wow some
funny people on it yeah and then what
Dumb and Dumber did uh did you have to
audition in front of Jim Carrey they
were because oh yeah yeah I had to read
I had to read with Jim Carrey uh several
times yeah and Jeff Daniels are just Jim
k no at the end of the process it was
down to me and Jeff Daniels I remember
sitting in the lobby at the final
audition it was me and Jeff Daniels
sitting there and they decided because
at the time was it the role of the the
the highway patrol officer no this was
for the the lead role next to Jim oh
damn so you didn't get that so well I'm
sitting in the lobby I'm a kid from
Toronto has never done a thing acting
wise and I'm sitting beside Jeff Daniels
who's been nominated for Oscars and I
thought back then I think I know which
way this was going to go but they loved
me and so I was right there just down to
me and him and then because the guys
love me they offered me the the highway
patrol uh role he said they we feel bad
but would you want to do this for all I
said yeah you guys don't owe me anything
I'd love to so it was a hilarious role
oh thank you yeah it was really fun
pumpkin pie here because it freaked yeah
so you keep your mouth shut if you know
what's good for you yeah yeah I remember
yeah sipping back on his old cough
medicine uh yeah did you improvise a lot
of those lines
I'd say I'd say half of it half of it I
improvised and they were laughing their
ass off at it well yeah and the
fairlease basically said to me that you
know we did about we did about five or
six takes off the script and again this
was my first movie so I was terrified
and they said okay Harlan that's good
now we want to do some more takes and I
said okay and and they said now do it
your way and I go what do you mean they
said do it the Harlan way
and at first I was like wait and then I
wasn't I just went [ __ ] I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna stall like they just
opened the gates for me so we went and
did it again and then I just improvised
all this stuff and in which take made
that which one I'd say 50 of all the
improvised stuff so the Fairly brothers
are great guys and you know about how
they grew up do you ever hear the story
about his dad was a doctor right yeah so
it's like two brothers and I think maybe
they had a sister or whatever and Mom
and just an Irish family and I I would
tell you a story so this is how [ __ ]
up this how great this family was but
also dad and mom it was all about comedy
in that household dad was a doctor I
think Mom was a housewife
and so uh it's a Sunday morning the boys
have been out and Peter sits down
they're gonna watch the football game
Peter goes ah
Jesus and this dad goes what's up
because my ass hurts
is that and and this dad goes what and
he goes my ass just it's killing me and
he goes what do you mean your ass he
goes it's my [ __ ] it's like it feels
like it's on fire man how old is he
25 oh okay oh 25 okay 27 okay so his
dad's like what do you mean your ass is
what are you you think it was my [ __ ]
my [ __ ] feels like it's just like I
don't know just [ __ ] somebody kicked
me in the [ __ ] or something like that
this dad goes his dad's a doctor he goes
like your [ __ ] he goes yeah man I
can't even I can barely sit on this
thing
and he goes let me see your [ __ ]
because I don't want to show you mad as
well because let me see your ass I'm a
doctor please let me show you [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] that's not normal yeah and
he's like I don't want to show you my
[ __ ] because let me see your [ __ ]
I mean you know this is you know so
Peter that's what he does his dad Peter
goes oh fine takes the pants off and he
bends down and no and his dad looks at
us and he's got a condom in his [ __ ]
and his dad goes his dad goes his dad
goes oh Jesus man show your mom show
your mom and so he's like whatever his
name is
him she comes in she goes oh God Peter
and that was a joke he did on his dad oh
well yes hilarious I stuck up comment
but then so you went Dumb and Dumber and
then the next big thing was uh something
about Mary because even in that scene
with the Farley brothers
you know he's like well if they come out
with six minutes
[Music]
my next movie after Dumb and Dumber was
actually a movie called Down Periscope
which was a submarine audition for that
you did oh yeah I auditioned for that oh
I wish you got it we would have had so
much fun they wanted me to play that the
big the badass guy but I wasn't big or
strong enough I didn't that guy right
there that guy yeah that guy Brad he was
a cool guy but oh it was so fun yeah it
was a submarine movie with the Kelsey
Graham cast yeah it was a blast who is
the gal
yeah you proposed to me but I wasn't
having it now how'd that movie do
it did uh sort of medium range you know
it wasn't a monster I mean how many
people are lining up to go see a
submarine movie you know like Rob
Schneider was in it yeah Rob
Kelsey Grammer yeah but and then the
Farley brothers must have liked you
because then if you go Dumb and Dumber
and then the next I mean they're big
boys Something About Mary was massive
yeah yeah that was uh that that was uh
you know what's funny about that when I
see that somebody I just I remember
auditioning for that like there's so
many actors that have come and gone
yeah do you know what I mean like you
see you're like you see that and I
remember a lot of them were working a
lot they'd have a Spate they'd run
they'd ever run for about three years
and then you never [ __ ] hear about
them again yeah Jim let me see his uh
red carpet outfit remember how many
movies Judge Reinhold was in remember
that I see him in the nope go back to
the images see see him down there on the
Red Door yeah what's the outfit there oh
a jumper see I dig that well that was
for uh something about marriage oh yeah
that's something God I don't even
remember that I've never and you had the
chops yeah yeah now good night Nelly
Furtado
I've never heard anybody use that
expression but I hear you on that yeah
yeah you were you were um
unconventionally handsome well at the at
the at the Red Carpet for uh Down
Periscope I uh I sort of took the whole
acting thing as a joke I never took it
very seriously I just my whole Mo with
entertainment is It's Entertainment
let's have fun so I never I never really
took anything too seriously and so when
I did the the um the thing for uh the
red carpet for Down Periscope I went to
the costume store and you know William H
Macy was in the movie and all these uh
all these serious actors were in the
movie and I bought a thespian costume
like an old Shakespearean with with
black striped leotards and a cap with
the feather and like the ruffled
shoulders and everything and you know
they sent a limo for me and I remember
my girlfriend at the time was a serious
actress and she wasn't really too happy
about it and I pop out I remember
popping out of the limo they opened the
door and I jump out dressed as a
thesbian and Kelsey the grammar is just
standing there like glaring at me and I
was inside I was dying I was just sort
of mocking the whole like yeah he's a
sweetheart though oh he was a nice guy
but I don't think he liked the whole uh
the uh 14th century thespian he's the
lead did you ever see Kelsey grammer's
tragic family story no you ever see that
no such a nice guy like literally his
entire family died
Colbert yeah well his Hypno his two
brothers and dad died in a plane but
this is different like this is like uh
50 years since customer younger sister
it was brutally murdered when she was
18. I think just her though right no he
had a bunch of others click on that chin
his father was murdered by anti-white
cab driver during a wave of racial
violence
his sister was kidnapped in murder and
Colorado Springs horrible into 1980s two
teenage half brothers died in the scuba
diving a lot of death I mean the guy
[ __ ] it's like he can't catch a break
I don't think he's bad luck it's cursed
two your two of your brothers I'm not
going to Christmas at that house no no
and the nicest man in the world just
yeah that's uh that's heartbreaking good
night good night
let's take a little break from chatting
with these two older gentlemen because
I'm here to talk to you about a company
that I ride and I ride hard for I'm
talking about my friends at Rogue
nicotine if you're a regular viewer find
the kid shop show golden hour Food Truck
Diaries calabas's fight campaign fight
by fight
night flashbacks jeez I do too much
you'll notice one thing and one thing
only I'm on Rogue nicotine I use them
every freaking day so you guys know how
much I love Rogue I asked them to be
part of my network because I love and
Trust Rogue nicotine they have the best
flavors on the planet my go-to is Apple
and lemon right now but I switch it up
might do the berry might do peppermint I
do
um the Wintergreen they have a cool
cinnamon one I enjoy all the flavors and
because the flavor is intense Rogue
destroys anything else out there you get
the pouches in three or six milligrams I
do six because I know Punk all right so
if you want to just get started probably
start with the three like I did then you
graduate to six beyond the pouches Rogue
also makes other great nicotine products
like gum tablets lozengers all right but
I'm a pouch guy so if you want to try
those other uh sources of nicotine
through the lozengers or the gum or the
tablets Rogue has that too I take them
anywhere I want that's why I love it I
take it to the airport the planes and
green rooms podcast Studios I take the
gym I take it everywhere there's no
restrictions Rogue is my go-to source
for nicotine alright I love it and if
you want to try the pouches like me or
the gums tablets everyone get your
nicotine go to Rogue nicotine.com use
the code rogue20 for 20 off your order
off these delicious little pouches
that's right Rogue 20 for 20 off your
order again Rogue 20 for 20 off your
entire order of the best of the best the
best nicotine on the planet I'm talking
about Rogue Daddy all right underage
sales prohibited warning this product
contains nicotine nicotine is an
addictive chemical for more information
visit Rogue nicotine.com now let's get
back to the program
um look we've been talking about a lot
of dark stuff and I kind of light in the
mood here do you guys like crafts oh
yeah you do I like crafts I love it yeah
oh great well I do this thing on this
did you have a side hustle yeah I do a
thing I call crinkle crafts and uh it's
it's Craft season and and I call it
crinkle crafts because crafts are kind
of fun and cute and and cute stuff makes
you like
kind of crinkle your you ever do a
little nose
yeah yeah so cute yeah but this is a hit
at the when you're you're giving the old
people well this is for old folks this
is for young this is for a crafts kind
of cross it's it's yes great word nobody
knows and uh so crinkle crafts if I if
you guys are up for it I could bring it
on I brought one of my craft kits and uh
you can do we can do a little if we have
time yeah I wondered why you brought
that bag and it always makes me nervous
I don't know if there's a small bobcat
in there no no but there is there is a
small uh a small baby oh
people can do at home okay
um let me get some of the gear out we
got oh okay that's sweet relish though
I hope there's a hot dog involved there
will be you're searching your bag like
an old man because you're it's so funny
you said that because uh part of it is
is this and then part of it is uh hot
dogs are the second part well we're
gonna have fun I like this okay uh do
you do this at Burning Man no this is
something I do at community centers I've
got a showing tonight at The Armenian
Community Center in Glendale if you guys
have time to drop by great community of
the Armenian community so these are a
lot of fun if you'll hand me the the the
the doll and this is a lot of fun so our
first craft we call it peanut butter
eyes I don't know if you guys have ever
seen a crinkle crafts and what we do
that's crunchy peanut butter and which I
yeah I like yeah so what you do is you
just dip dip into with a spoon or a
spatula does it have to be crunchy
crunchy I like crunchy because of the
texture yeah and this is called peanut
butter eyes and what you do is you just
get your and you just get right over the
eyes like that
and then you get on one eye
and then you just
right there let's get a little more this
is all part of the crinkle craft well if
you're gonna laugh no no we're not no
I'm having no it's very you know it's
it's soothing as you're doing this is
soothing yeah and then you got you got
uh
well it's crinkle craft it's a toy Brian
no I got it it's called peanut butter
eyes and then what we do is if you want
to have more fun with your crinkle cuffs
we do um peanut butter eyes and maybe
relish head oh okay and what we do you
get a bottle well if I could do it my
way sorry that's easy you get you're
relish and you just kind of glomp it on
baby's head and give it a cute little
dollop yeah and uh it just makes it just
sort of adds texture to the whole thing
and then if you want you can scoop for
kids if you want to scoop you can do
peanut butter relish see I like that
collab yeah that yeah you just that kind
of please don't get it all over our
studio well if you can let me do the
things
you are you in or not be no I'm in I'm
in is that peanut butter for the
holidays it's pretty amazing and then
it's so funny your instinct went to hot
dogs and if you could hold hold the baby
you got it yep yeah this is really chick
we get some napkins or something because
he's getting relish everywhere oh it's
not too bad okay
all right
no that's uh here we have you can smell
the relish I thought you brought hot
dogs this is fun and this is this next
craft is almost therapeutic any of you
chant or meditate I do I do a lot of
Buddhism you do yeah how often do you
check yeah
how often do you chant pretty much every
morning and night I'm a Buddhist oh
great okay
what do you do this is called baby
wiener face and what you think
well okay no no it's fine it's just what
you do is you get a it's funny you had
an instant because you take out the
wiener and this is very therapeutic hand
me the crinkle craft child yep and what
you do guys is you just get the meat and
you just roll it up the baby's face yeah
and rolling it up and down it sort of
soothes the soul yeah tight rolls too
yeah well that that'd be OT right
occupational therapy would anyone like
to try the crinkles
I learned by watching yeah well if you
just roll the meat the wiener all over
the baby's foot yeah now that's then
everything here is legal right pretty
much yeah and sometimes if you're
feeling aggressive if you have anger man
you can smack oh yeah yeah I know which
smacks yes therapeutic yeah or you can
even stab okay oh well this is if you've
got anger but this is
having the baby in the in the peanut
butter ice and I think that's that's I'm
sure if you're really mad you probably
up into bratwurst yeah you could just
slap it over right that's no I know but
we're making a mess now well I'm trying
to it's crinkle crap I know but I'm sure
is enthusiastic
I think this is when you get demonetized
I'm not sure I don't think so no no it's
a toy we should remind people it is a
fake baby and if you think it's real
right go watch the show you're right
you're right um trying to help people
he's trying to raise the mood what hey
Brian you want to talk about death no
you want another burning you want to
tell a story tell us another person's
family that died there's a bird there's
a hot dog there's half a dog there well
that's part of you know no one said uh
crafts are uh easy no I'm not saying
they are but so that would be the end of
The Craft yeah and what we'd do is and
the money we make selling these craft
kits is you can send money to Cinnamon
Angels fly fly away all the proceeds go
to that and you can send it directly to
my venmo at Harlan Williams and then we
you make sure we make sure it's over
minimum donations we like that we like a
hundred dollar starting block and to
help for the kids is there a maximum
because I know no Max no Max but at
least a hundred to get it started how
much how much of the money goes to
running the organization and how much
actually goes to the kids well I'm sorry
to ask these questions yeah I feel like
I'm being audited sort of yeah
the creative and not focus so much on
the finances who he's helping I'm sorry
think about the children uh someone at a
mall near Cinnabon as you mentioned
falling to the ground ankles puffing up
foam eyes eyes bleeding anal warts
popping up I mean well this is some of
them some of these cinnamon children
it's hard to you know when you get that
smell of Cinnabon it's hard enough
relish right now relish and hot dogs
right now that would be baby wiener face
a relish head peanut butter eyes
I could send you one of my craft kits if
you for that I will get our address to
you okay I feel like Brian's judging a
little bit
no no I'm not I'm sure because you you
kind of judged them for not you know
burning man yeah and then you judge them
for what happened with the bobcat and
Scotty McCarthy kind of like a child
what's it what was that name
um I I just worry sometimes and that
when you do that with a doll and you
have this essential ritual that looked
like a ritual that sometimes you can
conjure spirits and sometimes you can
open portals to a darker end no uh Mark
of the beef yeah why don't you go back
to Epstein Island hey I've never been
there are you kidding me I'm sorry I'm
sorry yeah you know what it is you're
not open-minded no I'm trying that's
what's going on you know where he when
he went to Epstein's Island from Welcome
Back Cotter he was over there oh wow Mr
okay bad joe
you know I worked with him you did I did
so you have been to Epstein's Island you
were passed away Jeffrey everything no
no no with uh Epstein from Welcome Back
Cotter oh really old
and he played our brother our oldest
brother he passed away passed away oh my
god wow what a performance yeah yeah no
not that wasn't part of the profession
oh yeah I thought maybe you acted him to
death you were a there he is oh wow old
school yeah passed away though he was he
was not old again a lot of death yeah
that's why I'm glad I brought it up I
appreciate you mixing it up otherwise
it's so dark I think crinkle crafts
really listen we're gonna double down on
death you know twitch who was the uh the
DJ for Ellen my girl woke up my girl
woke up almost three beautiful children
his wife was my girl my girl literally
ruined himself in the chest why he did
well [ __ ] if I knew him prevent it I
don't know dude does anyone
my girl used to watch we have a grill on
the back watch this boy watch how
amazing he is oh you him dancing and
then also with Ellen's stuff like then
he started to like host the show he was
producing his own shows oh this is for
Real yeah
down death
his kids were gorgeous his wife gorgeous
I know and they would dance and it was
close with him Aubry Marcus oh man do
you know do we know what did he suffer
from depression I have no I would assume
I don't know man I know as much as this
as I do the guy who ran to the fire yeah
it makes no [ __ ] sense man
hmm
damn it crazy
I mean I don't know what to say about it
man my girl woke up and she just was so
messed up I thought it was like
clickbait because you know I read the
the news every morning it popped up and
I was like it has to be like a weird
thing you know because he's young he's
40. damn near my age I was like also
three children think about the despair
[ __ ] man
[ __ ] maybe we should get one of those
babies out and do the peanut butter
thing again no no we're good all right
let's go to current events that gets us
in a current events current events with
harlems good morning American anchors
huh yeah
or questions
uh questions for her let's get the
questions so we uh asked the fans to
submit questions for you Harlan thank
you I got my Cactus Cooler oh yeah I'm
ready for questions I've never even
heard of Cactus Cooler you will okay
that your company
well there is cinnamon in the
ingredients oh man so it's not for
everybody it's not forever be careful
it's not for everybody this is a little
bit longer but so Mr Holland Williams my
father and I have always been distant
he's 25 years military and I'm the guy
in high school who pressed his naked
butt cheeks against things hilarious uh
we bonded for the first time though
watching Rocket Man I'm 35 and left and
I guess we're laughing our dicks off
even today we reminisce about your egg
cheese and liverwurst sandwich and he
calls me John Jacob Jingleheimer Schmidt
is there a movie in which you tie great
sentimental value like I do with rocket
man thanks thanks guys and thank you for
bringing back fan questions good
question John Michael John Michael that
that's a very common type of email uh
and comment that I get from people in
real life for some reason Rocket Man
really bonded families it's a massive
movie and in particular a bonded
um like Fathers and Sons and Daughters
it was a real kind of really yeah I get
it so much more than any other body of
work I've done and it's not the Elton
John Rocket Man it's a rocket man it was
a comedy I did about the first guy to go
to Mars I played Rocket Man and we're
the first drama it's a full-on comedy
it's like but um
but uh it really Drew people together
I've been Rocky Mansion yeah and as far
as the second
um question about is there something
sentimental about a movie
if I can go back to Dumb and Dumber
there's a line that I improvised in Dumb
and Dumber
whereas the highway patrolman I stopped
the guys and they're drinking beer and I
see the beer bottle and I go give me
that bottle of booze
and I go have you guys been sucking back
on Granddaddy's cough syrup yeah and so
that line originated from when I was a
little boy I would go to my grandparents
house and my grandfather used to like to
have a drink with whatever liquor I
don't know what it was but he called it
cough syrup so he'd say to my
grandmother go mother bring me some more
cough syrup they didn't want the kids to
know he was drinking and so when I was
improvising that scene because it was
booze that popped back into my head and
that's where the you boys been sucking
back on Granddaddy's cough syrup yeah
what's interesting so that there's this
rocket man this is what's weird for me
is
um my dad he didn't know and my Dad
loved he's alive but he still loves
movies yeah so he took me opening nights
about Mary I was when did Something
About Mary come out Jen I was young yeah
and that movie is not one of the great
one of the greatest movies all the time
it still holds up so 1998 so was that
seven so I was you know 15. wow 15 years
old and even at 15 so I was fine to go
to it but you know I'm with my dad when
Ben Stiller jacks off and then he's like
where's the [ __ ] oh yeah and he was you
know I'm with my Dad I'm like oh this is
so awkward and me my dad could not stop
laughing when he was like we're in the
[ __ ] yeah and then she's like does that
hair gel I've never seen my dad laughing
my grandma I mean him just bonded over
that and then it was like it was okay
like because then I was so tense right I
didn't want to laugh so finally once he
started laughing at that then it was
like oh it's weird Okay grandmother
my my grand my Italian grandmother what
how old is she I might have washed her
she's passed away uh okay about 20 years
ago okay
it's okay but thank you okay you're
welcome but she was laughing so hard at
that scene that she was like you know
when you're like wheezing and I went wow
my grandmother gets it you know because
that's such a that's like come you you
know what the bummer is like I don't
think like there's no comedies like that
today like I don't even know if they
could make that movie today they can but
they won't well the problem the hard way
they're good I think it's gonna come
back full circle if somebody's gonna
take the risk but right now it's like
they're so worried about offending this
group or that something about Mary like
obviously uh what Cameron Diaz in that
movie She's Dating all these other guys
so it's like yeah you know don't you
feel like we're we're worried about it
even who's worried about it on a podcast
that we worry about it well but just
sometimes it's like like it's in the
back of everybody's mind now oh is that
too much let me say this I'm worried
about because because the show and you
have employees and stuff like that
YouTube will demon monetize things if
it's according to them over the line or
if it's 21 or older so which affects
numbers which we've dealt with for you
know about two years now so that but
that at some point it's like all right
well you're conform to those rules or
you just keep doing what you're doing
it's gonna keep doing it keep doing we
conform to those rules I don't want to
do it I'm just picturing crinkle crafts
getting cut out of this show right
crinkle crafts
no never none of basketball that's
important to get out to people and I I
think the most important a lot of people
come on especially if they're friends
and they're thinking of that and you can
tell they're they're they're holding up
no one's everything that's why I love
Sam Tripoli you know on the fight and
Harlan Williams yeah he did crinkle
crafts because on fighting man I told
Santa Baby with a hot dog I told
everybody on yeah hot dog and relish and
then well there was therapy for me
though no no I know that don't judge bro
I'm not and it wasn't a real baby no
nobody died like on the blog
he's like a comic from the 90s if he's
more famously being canceled years ago
so he just shoots from the hip so before
we do fight mango fellas no restrictions
I talked to my guys at YouTube just
don't do anything crazy in the first
like two three minutes Sam's like no
dude that's easy yeah minute in
um I like [ __ ] fat chicks like
yeah really you went oh we're going
there all right we're going there I went
YouTube's going like it's demonetized
sandwich too much of nope go on Sam all
right down this road it's a live show do
your thing
got it you gotta let an episode slip
through where you don't it's not about
the money every now and then you mean my
entire network yeah I can't I do I I
won't do it if we have to you know do
this weird middle man thing yeah like no
who we are it's awesome glad to hear
that no it's not funny you don't censor
yourself never never I just find it it's
a bit frustrating that there's entities
out there that wanna centers whereas I
don't think they used to do that but now
they do but I think it'll come back
around where they I don't know I don't
think it'll come back around I do but I
think we're gonna get more and more
divided where they'll be at parallel
economies uh and and parallel levels of
entertainment to say the least so in
other words I think that that you're
gonna always have this group of people
that don't believe in fun and that are
offended professionally offended by
everything those people are over here
they're just a personality type
I'm going to ask you not to slip your
cactus juice when I'm talking like that
all right all right
and then you're going to have the rest
of us in the vast middle who want
comedy the way it should be yeah but
the other way they'll be they're going
to learn the hard way because the the
numbers don't cry like those people that
are doing that and playing that game and
making sure nobody's feeling good luck
with that hey it's not funny good luck
make money even those woke people
they're not buying tickets to it so it's
going to come back full circle and also
I think helps us is whether however you
feel about Elon Musk because you're
doing everything right now who is but
with him leaking those files on how they
were doing things at Twitter and
suppressing and you know making sure
accounts weren't seen and blacklisting
people I think that puts notice on these
other you know big corporations you know
with YouTube and Facebook and meta and
Instagram and Tick Tock where it's like
hey if Twitter's doing this you guys
doing this too so it's only going to be
a matter of time before they go we can't
keep doing this so I think it releases
the house did you see what Jack Dorsey
said let me read this yeah I sent this
to Chin I thought this was interesting
this is from Barstool there's a lot of
conversation about the Twitter files
here's my take and thoughts on how to
fix the issues identified I'll start
with the principles I've come to believe
based on everything I've learned an
experience through my past actions as a
Twitter co-founder and Lead social media
must be resilient to corporate and
government control
two only the original author may remove
content they produce wow number three
moderation is best implemented by
algorithmic choice I don't understand
that I know either
what does that mean and then I'm going
downtown I don't want to edit everything
I'll go back I don't want to edit
everything into 280 Char chunks so
here's the rest it goes to a difference
so he basically talks about how he got
compromised once there was like money
and special interest and you just got
out of hand so he was saying allowing
the government to have influences is a
massive mistake that he made and he's
taken accountability for it which
I completely gave up pushing for them
when an activist entered our stock in
2020. I no longer had hope of achieving
any of it as a public company with no
defense mechanisms lack of a dual class
shares being a key one Louis the next
paragraph okay the biggest mistake I
made was continue to invest in building
tools for us to manage the public
conversation versus building tools for
the people using Twitter to easily
manage it for themselves the burden is
burning the company with too much power
and openness to openness to significant
outside pressure such as advertising
budgets I generally think companies have
become far too powerful and that became
completely clear to me with our
suspension of Trump's account as I've
said before we did the right thing for
the public company business at the time
but the wrong thing for the internet and
Society wow I listen man load of
[ __ ] really I mean here's the guy
he's giving himself an exit window he
was the CEO
of a company that dealt in public
opinion and he let all this stuff happen
and acts like you know water got into
the framework and whoops I you're you're
in charge you're running the ship dude
you're the Mastermind yeah you let that
stuff happen and to act like now you're
back John I learned all this stuff but
my thing about someone like Jack Dorsey
in that is that I don't know that anyone
is equipped to deal with a monster you
create like that that became
Frankenstein and I and I don't know if
he ever had a skill set to be prescient
enough or or managerial enough to handle
the monster it became I think the lesson
here is that anybody in that at the
helmet compromise but anyway at the helm
of that ship might have been in a
position where okay this is good for our
shareholders this is good for the
business
but bad for the internet and things get
when your whole Board of director says
we have to suspend Trump's account and
there's a shitload of pressure so let me
give you the the converse thing Elon
Musk now takes over Twitter and opens it
up now you have a massive amount of
people
who say oh um this is hate speech I'm
leaving Twitter he also reinstates Trump
which has its own backlash to the tune
that a lot of liberal women and other
liberal people are not buying Teslas now
couple that with couple that with the
Europeans coming in with people other
people entering we couple that with
Twitter's never had more users I don't
know if that's true look it up Jen yeah
but Twitter also has some major problems
and he's military milking tests left
from Twitter so what I'm saying is that
damned if you do damned if you don't
right damned if you do damned if you
don't it's not damned if you do damned
if you don't it's like if you build
something and its sole purpose is to
allow the public Twitter downloads grows
since he took over here
no you got to be careful where you get
your news yeah so again you're using
Google right chin figure it out and I'm
not being mean I'm just saying you got
to realize like what's going to pop up
first and then what's really actually
happening Twitter has lost 50 of its top
100 advertisers since Elon took over and
that's he knew he was going to do that
but um you know the usage and the the
users have gone up since you took over
and has there's gonna be some don't get
it twisted like he doesn't know how to
run this company really he's doing what
he thinks is Right which to me is better
than what Twitter was doing yeah I'd
rather have this and again it's chaos I
don't have that to be suppressed and
only one side of the political line gets
to voice their opinion I think though he
is going to face a lot of the same
challenges that the original Twitter
staff disagree because of his but his
backing because this thing fails he
doesn't give a [ __ ] you don't need to be
compromised I don't know he's fine
either way Maybe
mainly in the U.S okay
interesting
there you go Twitter has grown in real
Elon Musk mainly in the U.S Twitter
downloads have increased wow
okay
uh he's a he's a leader and he there
it's I'm amazed that he's been so
demonized it's fascinating to me it's
like you guys need to you the mainstream
media you lost Trump now you need
another Boogeyman lost Trump Josh Rogan
especially but of course why wouldn't
they go for him Jesus like they're gonna
go for him because he's the guy he's a
Visionary he creates a lot of jokes but
then also left was able to push this
agenda for so long and they took money
and funding especially even with the
white house and he comes and goes we're
not doing that anymore but he's not
saying I'm gonna do what you guys do did
and now it's gonna meet you for the
right he's like you aren't doing it
right but I'm also not gonna Advocate on
the ride either it's it's wild when you
say the left too I don't even know who
are these people and what are this what
is the agenda why are you so mad at Elon
Musk honestly there are other things to
be mad at you know somebody said I had
Peter Zion on my podcast he's uh I just
wrote an amazing book and uh everybody
should read his book The End is just the
beginning you got to read that book
it'll yeah it's very important
um and and he said you know the United
States compared to China and all these
other countries that don't have the
population to sustain their economies
never mind the fact that they don't have
energy Independence and they have to
import it and they're not going to be
able to so China China 100 China 80
percent of China China needs to import
80 of its goods to growth but they have
the the capacity China is so overcrowded
oh it's so funny not overcrowded they're
overcrowded with old people they don't
have enough young people so they're not
they're not at replacement rates so
they're they're they don't have enough
young Believe It or Not China China for
three decades have had a one child
policy strictly enforced yes remind
remember this their ethnic minorities
like the uyghurs they have monitors
living in their houses to make sure that
they're they don't procreate on top of
that they're they're at 0.8 children per
woman which is the lowest in history
anywhere what that means is a this is a
disaster their population is very old
they don't have an enough young people
to even support their economy or their
old people they don't have a tax base
for that they don't even have enough
young people now they're telling young
people to have five kids they don't have
enough young kids to replace it's too
late G knows this the Chinese knows
they've known this for 10 years now they
have to figure out a way to get their
energy they're completely dependent on
foreign energy they cannot police their
own uh uh C's because their Navy sucks
and they're 30 years away from having a
Navy the United States Navy
we are 10 times stronger
the United States Navy 10 times stronger
than all the other navies combined and
what Peter Zion was saying was that you
know we're doing great in comparison the
world when we have these wars over
gender neutral bathrooms and puberty
blockers that's when you know as a
country you got no problems yeah you're
talking about countries like Russia and
and China especially China though and
Korea who have to import their own
energy that are going to have a tough
time
feeding themselves because they don't
have the materials they need for
artificial fertilizer it's a [ __ ]
disaster and when I talked to him I was
just like I mean it was he makes such an
amazing argument the the book is called
the end of the world is near and uh the
end of the world is just the beginning
the mapping the collapse of
globalization and I gotta tell you man
it was shocking he doesn't think and
this is a guy that has been doing this
forever he doesn't think China as you
know it is a country or Russia are going
to be countries in about 10 years
they're going to be they're going to be
fiefdoms they're going to be sort of uh
various republics run by you know
different Warlords that's no joke yeah
yeah
and by the way they're in the Ukrainian
War that's so far from over that's going
to go on for five years
and they want parts of Poland so the
stakes are crazy high they can't pull
out they can't leave it's going to be
Johnny good news over here go back to
people dying Peter Zion
we don't have problems
uh something happier I guess it's
happier I'm deep man I'm [ __ ] deep so
PornHub always reveals whatever there
was
it was deep I mean yeah so at the end of
the year PornHub always does these
reports about who's been searched the
most who's been down you know what kind
of porn what style
so this is uh they're 20. it never
aligns with me nope well she's about she
aligns with me who is she a Bella danger
she was like the one of the most popular
porn stars of 2022. well no I have a
theory on why she's so big because she
was dating Mike from uh Logan Paul right
the other girl oh that's a different a
different girl yeah okay so yeah yeah
I've seen her work it's impressive
really Alana Rhodes that's who a lot of
Roads that's right you know she's high
on the list yeah so these are the top
searches lesbian which again I'm most of
them I just don't mess with like lesbian
does nothing no it does nothing you know
like you're like like your craft bit I
need a wiener you know what I'm saying I
need I gotta see it I need peanut butter
some weiner
yeah what the [ __ ] is hentai that's what
I was wondering what's that Japanese uh
I think it's anime anime but then with
tentacles I think that's the one with
tentacles just to show you man America's
some freaks lesbian and then anime and
tentacle wieners Ebony Ebony like can I
get Asian all right threesome I mean
stepmom's always weird big dick
blasphemy ass I looked at how that does
oh is it
BBC big black dick okay big black [ __ ] I
I don't remember that one okay cream pie
Japanese okay okay Brendan's
Lana Rhodes second Riley Reed still
Violet Myers Angela White trending
search uh you should a lot of Rhodes and
uh uh Danger
they're they're they're like the Meryl
Streep
like that comparison can I see what can
I see that oh Brenda uh
yeah yeah okay she's fantastic Lana
Rhodes dated uh Mike from uh he's Logan
Paul's uh co-host oh wow of a reason
that's probably why she's so high on the
list now she's been popping for a hot
second she's gorgeous yeah gorgeous yeah
what are we doing good Lord yeah oh lord
lord yeah I don't watch porn
I I don't I swear to God I haven't
watched porn and I don't know how long
but now I'm gonna go around just cake
right now this doesn't turn me on in the
public doesn't turn me on what and this
is what they've searched the most in
each state I'm calling [ __ ] in
Colorado goth is number one
how dude yeah I don't know look at
Florida it's the British news
paper BBC that's right big black how
about New Orleans just as black yeah I
don't know and then Wisconsin's just
pegging
that was the top out of all the other
searches that's what they're saying the
range it's coming from like the internet
IP stuff I guess and then fear furries
on there yeah they have they have um you
you have access to their Master server I
guess and that's where you get a sense
the ones just smoking
I don't I don't know what that is of
course uh now you know the most uh
subscriptions to porn this might be
surprising for you guys you know how to
do the The Green Room dies so I do all
the research on the seats where I go in
them the number one uh state with the
most subscriptions to porn site Utah
that makes sense Mormons anywhere they
tell you not to [ __ ] people are going
[ __ ] or at least they got really yeah
yeah Harlan I know you lead prayer
circles I know you're aligned with the
Divine but what is your what is your
porn do you are you a porn guy do you
have a specific thing you're into no I
like pet videos you know like furry I
like crinkle crafts no no I like I like
watching videos of like a cat playing
with a Bollywood or a dog coming through
a dog door I I don't believe you I think
you're lying right now all right I feel
like Harlan would like like magazines
like old school ones oh as long as
there's pets oh you sip a tab
an old school Tad oh I don't drink diet
drinks guy sorry yeah what's your what's
your soda pop of choice well I have the
uh Cactus Cooler here I never even seen
those that looks like you bottled it in
your in your garage you have a bottling
would you like a slurp it looks like you
have an old school bottling operation
orange pineapple that sounds nice yeah
you want a slurp yeah sure why not I
wouldn't mind a little uh
a taquito with this would be nice A
little quesadilla yeah try it out
or maybe some alcohol
you get out of here you little pumpkin
pie here dead freak pass it on to Wild
Boy is that pretty sweet yeah yeah it's
nice though
remind me of the drink jasta back in the
day
that's a phantom that's a nice Phantom
that's Cactus Cooler it's a delicious
Phantom well you're saying that right I
like that you drink a heavy sugary drink
and you could give two [ __ ]
yeah that's that's what my [ __ ] stamp
says yeah and I like your striated
forearms thanks bro
a little bit of Fire
gotta keep those Oldies in line oh yeah
no I know what else you got Jen
just one more okay this is a simple one
then so this has been trending for some
reason I've never thought Brittany
Griner and Pete Davidson looked alike at
all but when she was in the plane
traveling back to America they had a
videotape over her she had because she
had the shaved head and then they
actually had the similar eyes I think
it's the condition so I'm not trying to
make fun of them but they've check it
out yeah she looks like Pete Davidson
similar like
yes yes I didn't realize her voice is
that deep dude it's really deep voice I
should dunk on you too
do you know where to head into no no no
no no no no
I think they took her to San Antonio to
the military base to the U.S
never mind everything will be fine
yep that's it that's a very deep voice
very deep voice it's a move huh play
some hoops but uh schultzy said it best
he did a pod with uh on brilliant idiots
with Charlemagne and he's like people
gonna keep the same energy all these
people say no bring you know get Britney
Spear Britney Spears get Brittany
grinder back in the States and he was
then go to the WNBA games because nobody
goes he's like where's the energy if
you're in this much support do the
energy and give back to what are you
looking at Jim so someone sent this in
and it looks
to another man that was Brian before he
cut his own hair
[Music]
which is an Italian this is the my worst
this is my least favorite kind of
massage [ __ ] off I don't even I've never
had a massage remember that scene in the
alien where the alien popped out of the
belly I feel like it's about to burst
out of that guy's Underpants too and I I
feel like that doesn't mean nothing is
bursting that guy's full of [ __ ] and
that doesn't it depends what it is if
it's that uh Matt the the muscle
activization technique you've done so
you've done Sports a long time high
level you've worked with the best people
yes oh sorry
what do you cry [ __ ] on what do you
believe in like massage obviously we
don't have enough time but I mean
chiropractor I don't you know you don't
[ __ ] snake oil yeah they're not even
doctors uh the m.a.t that muscle
activization technique stuff like Lauren
Landa I think came up with that and
that's I mean Peyton Manning did which
is what what is that where they get to
the like if there's an injured muscle
they go to the like basically where the
muscles at where it connects and they
fire that up to get blood flowing like
that stuff is legit yes like paint man
believed in so much when they won the
Super Bowl MVP that Lauren was basically
living like going on the road with him
like living with him Lauren Lauren along
with Leo flowers cured my back cured my
lower back for real how'd you hurt your
back guy I always had back problems this
[ __ ] Lauren Landau should I
exercise how did you hurt it do it like
you're kind of avoiding living close to
the Bone not an answer I take no [ __ ] I
live close to the Bone and I right or
wrong the minute I see it yeah let me
tell you something sometimes you gotta
you gotta use some torque sometimes to
come full circle back to burn a man
sometimes you get too close to the flame
sometimes you get too close to the
Flames by the way she's not answering I
want to know what fell on you at Home
Depot to hurt your back nothing fell on
me what happened guys you shoulder the
truth your lower back gots to take
someone
and I Gotta Throw bones and you know
when I throw bones whether it's my feet
the bones of my feet bones my hand you
got to get some torque this is going to
be Nelly Furtado doing satanic chants
right now how did you hurt your back kid
yeah I was a wrestler as a Young Man
nope
what was the exact moment you were
lifting what you fell down a cliff look
man you were riding Dolly Parton
whatever it was it was years of sports
guys
I don't think he has a bad news not
anymore I don't know yeah not anymore I
don't stop doing that you're dismissing
your box stop dissing me you don't know
that answer when did you hurt it you
want to feel sorry for you right I have
a scar on my arm I know I was attacked
by a mountain lion I know what that scar
is hold on hold on you were attacked by
a mountain lion no don't don't make this
about it oh yeah don't switch gears
let's go Holly what pollywog Pete okay
well look man maybe part of his people
not [ __ ] buying me at my money right
now maybe people not buying me at my
word you know I'm just right now both of
you guys are nothing how did you get in
a car accident did you roll down a hill
with one of your boyfriends what
happened what how did you no I didn't
your fourth vertebrae I never said it
was my fourth birthday how did you hurt
your back there trial of my tits stop
calling me names tell us why you need to
see these specials I feel like you're
just looking for sympathy you guys got
me chasing my own tail now my back is
starting to hurt I'm I'm seizing up I've
been beat up we've had two guests on and
it's been Monday and Wednesday back to
back getting beat up I'm not being I'm
not being taken at my word all I'm
asking is what happened
did someone kick you in the back no I
probably didn't get kicked in the back
but I've been kicked at and I had to
move back an answer back I come back
with what I have you throw bones at me
I'm gonna come back with what I have wow
bro General dude I think I answered that
question no
and real well really you are so far away
from the answer your breath smells like
gingivitis at its beginnings
put a metaphor he needs to do he needs
to go to Bell or yours you need to go to
Birdman and get real with yourself yeah
jump in
that's in poor taste well either you're
going to answer us so you're not
barbecue Billy let's go guy
that might be the best how hard is it to
know how you hurt your back I got oldies
at the senior center that no one nurse
went out okay
this has been Harlan Williams ladies and
gentlemen I hope you enjoyed this
episode he's going to be on tour Harlan
your stand-up comedy tour when not doing
uh a puppy show and crinkle crafts
you'll be at the Crystal Bay Club that
already happened wow stand up live Jimmy
Kimmel Vegas Jimmy Kimmel's Comedy Club
Las Vegas December 15th to 18th then
well the great stand up live Phoenix AZ
January 20th 22nd love that room you
know what I really want to plug though
guys what buddy outside of crinkle
crafts is I have a podcast I do now well
thanks for having us on called the
Harlan highway it's new it's brand new
like five months it's brand new okay
great podcast the kid was on what came
on would you want to come on I'm in dude
you would yeah can we paint babies with
peanut butter you'll see what'll happen
guys I have no idea what might happen
but it's called the Harlan Highway and
I'd love you guys to check it out and
then I also have my uh website
harbling.com where I hand draw my own
t-shirts oh sweet you do yeah can I see
some of those
yeah.com friend of the show Wilson and I
draw these shirts and if you scroll down
you can go to the gallery there they are
I like the Kung Fu carrot I like the the
Harlan face on that I don't know click
that little arrow on the right you can
scroll through them and you can order
one of one oh that's a specific but if
you go faster I'd love you to make some
of my merch what would you do for me
that little arrow there on the right
there's for some reason it goes to that
cup keep clicking there there it is I
drove right on the shirts with sharpies
really man I saw the original shirt and
then after the original sold we make
prints of all of them there's a stinky
squid fart I know you like those I love
those that's great that's why they call
you a calamari Pete oh wow over at the
chiropractor clinic I like the
Frankenstein yeah yeah you're definitely
an animator these are good
my eyes ah Dear God
that's a great man thanks man wow that's
how Brian hurt his back yeah
that's a picture of you heard of your
back so you said your own the answer the
whole time
God damn it Harlan that's right we love
you man thank you
I'll be in Boston Massachusetts Live
Boston December 29th 30 31 San Diego
California Mike drop Comedy Club January
5 6 7 harling Williams Supply come down
and open for me Fort Wayne Indiana
Summit Comedy Club January 13 14. I got
Danny of Florida January 19 2021
Nashville Tennessee March two three four
New York City Sony Hall tickets left
March 11th one night only in New York
City then West Nyack New York Levity
Live March 16th and daddy's taking
February off those are in March
um we I think we only added one day so
far but uh 2023 is going to be busy but
we have uh the tickets be up soon but
it's Tampa Improv Tampa Bay Florida is
mar I'm sorry it's January
20
through the 21st and that will be up in
the next I'm in Springfield Missouri
Springfield where the Simpsons is from
that's not true February 3rd to the 4th
the Naples Oklahoma City's on the Tacoma
get your tickets uh thinkboy.com
f-a-t-kz.com all right Harlan we love
you dude thank you for having me guys
yeah such a good time thank you so much
appreciate you thank you